and now ladies and gentlemen a very
special friend of Oscar without whom
this show would not be official mr. Bob
Hope
thank you thank you moral she beautiful
that's what we call Acapulco gold Thank
You Lady gentlemen I'm Bob Hope no Nats
at this affair as up the Yangtze without
a ping-pong paddle actually I'm your
next friend of the Oscar what else it
takes talent to be an enemy no but I am
I am a friend of Oscar and after what
he's done to me for the past 30 years
you might say were intimates they
actually wanted a stand-up comedian at
this point which is me after what I lose
on April of 15 I have to stand up
believe me but I want to tell you this
is our big night because winning an
Oscar means never having to say you're
sorry
oh by the way the management has asked
me to make a special announcement in
case of an earthquake you will walk to
the nearest exit I'll grab the Oscars
and run but this is a great night for
Hollywood tonight we set aside petty
differences forget old feuds and start
new ones this is the finish of the Oscar
race the final pit stop for [ __ ]
talents to have their egos inflated it's
lucky I'm not the jealous type but what
a turnout here everybody's here even
Howard Hughes he's sitting in that empty
seat in the back row but this is the
real Hollywood magic this glamorous
audience with their gleaming diamonds
beautiful gowns and expensive quaff
yours you can't tell the 40% who are
working from the 60% unemployed
but it is it is an elegant and elegant
audience all those furs diamonds rubies
emeralds and the women look good too
we have dignitaries here from the
furthest points of the globe potentates
Maharaja's mayor your tea but this is a
strange business just think Frank
Sinatra announced he was quitting show
business and they gave him a
Humanitarian Award
I refuse to believe they're trying to
tell me something no I really hate the
see franco-italian singers are so rare
but this has been a strange year in our
business yesterday I saw a movie that
didn't have Elliott Gould in it but it's
a great night I'm rooting for love story
to win because the producer was so brave
imagine having the courage the audacity
and the daring in today's market to make
a picture about a boy falling in love
with a girl I took my wife to see
lobster and she cried all the way
through the whole movie they get pretty
upset when you make them pay their own
way no we've got to go back to movies
when when the girl says I love you it's
a declaration not a demonstration but
the kind of pictures are making with the
kind of pictures they're making these
days you can win an Oscar without
getting out of bed actually I liked it
better when you walked out of a movie
crying because the story was sad not
because you weren't built like the star
and a lot of titles were deceptive this
year who would ever guess that five Easy
Pieces was about one male piano player I
know this is the year of kinky sex but
the Owl and the Pussycat and how about
cold turkey did you ever think you could
make a picture about a frigid bird
Airport was a movie about a plane that
takes off with a Mad Bomber on board and
a pilot who can't pass the balloon test
that plane must have been called the
flying Titanic
then there's where's Papa based on the
Diary of Richard zanuck
the babymaker the Bing Crosby story
Patton was the story of a man who wanted
to win the war but not the Oscar it's
it's funny his nomination for Patton in
World War two may start World War 3
no but I think George see Scott is out
here because as I parked my car there
was a guy with a chest full of medals
and a swagger stick letting all the air
out of the tires not only that as I
passed him he slapped me for being out
of uniform
and how about Helen Hayes being winning
again for her performance and Airport
whatever though she got an Oscar for her
performance here in 1932 and here she is
again how greedy can you get and Kerry
Snodgrass was nominated for a diary of a
mad housewife that wonderful movie about
Martha Mitchell
and of course everyone was delighted
when Chief Dan George was nominated it's
the greatest thing that's happened to
the Indians since John Duane's horse got
hoof-and-mouth disease Chief Dan George
he was alright but why couldn't they
have given that part to an American and
Alex Weldon was nominated for special
visual effects in Patton and if George
Scott wins and walks on the stage we'll
find out how good Alex really is Ryan
O'Neal not only won a nomination he
started a whole new category leading boy
as if anyone as if anyone that young
could feel any real emotion I don't know
why they use him when there's so many
great more mature lovers laying around
I'm only kidding I don't have a jealous
bone in my body on a solid lump of green
blubber ladies and gentlemen as we all
know the industry is having a few
problems not the least of which is
finding an Italian to appear in The
Godfather
and Hollywood has has to Swit stand more
than money pressures in that case I've
seen the rewritten script of the
Godfather and it's the most exciting
account I've ever read about the Cub
Scouts I had no idea those little tykes
control that many judges tonight the
winners will be go home with an Oscar
tucked under their arm for the first
time the Academy has come up with
something for the losers a free
scholarship to a skydiving school this
year Hollywood really has to economize
last year the winners celebrated with
champagne and caviar at the sentry
plasma this year it's kool-aid and pizza
Shakey's that's the way it is in
Hollywood today I met a panhandle of the
other day and I said why don't you get
yourself a job he said what and give up
show business
in fact some movie people met with
President Nixon at San Clemente about
this the other day trying to get a tax
break they sent Charlton Heston because
he's president the Screen Actors Guild
and because he's experienced with
miracles Heston's a very persuasive
talker and after the conference Charlton
was wearing the business suit and the
president was wearing a sheet no we sent
all the heads of the studios to plead
poverty mr. Luke Dixon looked out the
window at their cars and they were
bigger than airforce one mr. Nixon
admitted he is not too knowledgeable
about movies he thought mash was a
documentary about Ag nourish tea shots
in conclusion I just want to say that
many of us come here each year expecting
fate to smile down on us and what do we
get the fallout from Brewster McCloud
but such is the prestige of this
occasion that there is honor even in
losing in any event with the massage
parlors closed I wasn't doing anything
else tonight
and
and I'll be here in case George see
Scott really doesn't want it thank you
very much